y
[Música]
el pentágono desmintió que se esté
obstaculizando la transferencia de poder
al equipo del presidente de electo joe
biden tras sus señalamientos entretanto
la cámara de representantes de mayoría
demócrata aprobó el proyecto de ley que
aumenta de 600 a 2000 dólares la ayuda
directa a estadounidenses afectados por
la pandemia y anuló el veto de trump a
la ley de defensa
hay polémica en colombia luego de que se
anunciara un aumento del salario mínimo
mensual del 35 % para 2021 lo que
equivale a alrededor de 10 dólares la
controversia se centra en que hace
algunos días el salario de los
congresistas no sólo subió un 5,1 por
ciento aproximadamente 480 dólares sino
que este aumento será retroactivo desde
enero de 2020
la ong reporteros sin fronteras alertó
sobre los asesinatos de periodistas en
países que no están en guerra en méxico
india pakistán y honduras ocurrió la
mayoría de los crímenes la organización
advierte que aunque la cifra es cercana
a la del año pasado durante 2020 se
redujeron considerablemente los
reportajes en terreno
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos esta emisión de noticias en
eeuu porque el presidente de electo joe
biden responsabilizó a los jefes del
pentágono y de la oficina de gestión y
presupuesto de intentar obstaculizar la
transición de poder el demócrata señaló
que es irresponsable que ambas
instituciones estén entregando
información insuficiente el pentã gono
desmintió las acusaciones
de algunas agencias nuestros equipos
recibieron cooperación ejemplar por
parte del personal en otras
principalmente en el departamento de
defensa
hemos encontrado obstrucción por parte
del liderazgo político de ese
departamento y la verdad es que muchas
agencias que son críticas para nuestra
seguridad han sufrido un daño enorme
muchas de ellas han sido vaciadas de
personal capacidad y moral moral
confesional
continuamos en washington la cámara de
representantes aprobó el proyecto de ley
que aumenta de 600 a 2000 dólares el
pago directo a estadounidenses afectados
por el cob y 19 con 275 votos a favor y
134 en contra el incremento había sido
exigido por el presidente de trump y
ahora la medida pasa al senado donde se
prevé que enfrente el rechazo de la
mayoría republicana en la misma sesión
la cámara anuló el veto que el jefe de
estado le había dado al proyecto de ley
de defensa de 740 mil millones de
dólares la normativa también pasa al
senado en caso de apoyar la decisión de
la cámara sería la primera anulación de
veto en la presidencia de trump para
ambas para dar luz verde a ambas
iniciativas
la cámara logró obtener una mayoría de
al menos dos tercios
vamos a colombia porque hay polémica por
el aumento del salario mínimo mensual
que quedó fijado en un 35 por ciento lo
que equivale a cerca de 10 dólares y
dejan 290 dólares el monto total la
medida se produce luego de que hace
algunos días se incrementará en 51
el sueldo de congresistas lo que
equivale a 480 dólares y deja sus
honorarios en alrededor de 10 mil
dólares mensuales el aumento a los
legisladores corresponde a la vigencia
de 2020 y será retroactivo desde enero
en france24 hablamos con voces del
gobierno y la oposición para analizar
este tema
280 congresistas integran las dos
cámaras del legislativo colombiano todos
como si de un regalo de navidad se
tratara recibieron el 24 de diciembre
mediante este decreto presidencial el
monto de su aumento salarial para 2020
una subida del 5 12 por ciento de
carácter retroactivo este salario de los
parlamentarios pasa así de 9.300 de 73
dólares a 9 mil 853 dólares mensuales en
un país con un salario mínimo que para
2021 pasará de 280 a 290 dólares
este mensaje es nefasto y además ayuda
muchísimo a esa de legitimación y esa
desconfianza que ya de por sí la
ciudadanía tiene del congreso de la
república en los partidos de gobierno
los partidos tradicionales en colombia
nunca nos han permitido que se aprueben
leyes que permitan reducir el salario y
que estemos muchísimo más acordes
sintonía contra con la ciudadanía
desde el ejecutivo explican que este
aumento es una obligación constitucional
y sostienen que el repunte
inferior al de años anteriores y después
de haberlo analizado si se podría
recortar o se podría aplazar nos dimos
cuenta que la ley nos obligaba a tener
esos reajustes y por eso se expidió el
decreto que como ustedes lo decían muy
bien es un decreto que se expide para el
año 2020 cuando los funcionarios y el
salario mínimo en colombia creció un 6%
al congreso se inició una reducción y
tiene un un incremento en 5.1 por ciento
no es la primera vez que el sueldo de
los congresistas se convierte en un
debate público hace dos años el país
acudió a las urnas en una consulta
contra la corrupción que entre sus
medidas incluía una reducción del
salario de los legisladores sin embargo
el referendo no consiguió el mínimo de
participación exigido por la ley
hablamos ahora de kobe 19 porque
argentina está a pocas horas de iniciar
la campaña de inmunización con la vacuna
rusa y hay 300.000 dosis en el país
destinadas al personal sanitario y se
prevé que en las próximas semanas
lleguen más vacunas hasta que se
complete en 10 millones en 2021 desde
buenos aires nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoi nos da más detalles al
respecto
este martes comienza en argentina el
operativo de vacunación contra el kobe
19 que el gobierno asegura será el más
grande en su tipo en la historia del
país en esta primera etapa serán 300.000
dosis de la vacuna sputniks y la
prioridad la tendrán los trabajadores de
la salud es un proceso que no ha estado
exento de críticas entre ellas el hecho
de que la inoculación esté comenzando
antes de que se hayan publicado los
resultados del estudio de fase 3 de esta
vacuna desarrollada por el instituto
gamma leia ruso la expectativa es y que
esta publicación ocurre en los próximos
días o tal vez semanas y en los primeros
meses de 2021 el gobierno espera recibir
millones de dosis de esta misma vacuna
también de la de oxford y astrazéneca y
están negociando con otros proveedores
de vacunas también ha firmado un
convenio por 28 millones de dólares con
el mecanismo kóvacs de la organización
mundial de la salud para recibir otras
posibles vacunas a través
por otra parte vale recordar que en
argentina la vacunación contra el coi 19
es gratuita y voluntaria
continuamos en argentina porque el
senado debatirá en las próximas horas el
histórico proyecto de ley que busca
legalizar la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo se espera que la votación se
decida con un margen muy estrecho si los
legisladores dan luz verde a esta
iniciativa argentina se convertiría en
el país más grande de latinoamérica en
consagrar el derecho al aborto tal y
como está ahora las mujeres sólo pueden
interrumpir su embarazo en casos de
violación o si su vida está en peligro
veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe
una muestra de fuerza en la víspera de
un debate fundamental en el senado los
manifestantes tomaron las calles de
buenos aires- llamando a los
legisladores a rechazar la reforma legal
que legalizaría la interrupción del
embarazo un proyecto que fue aprobado
casi tres semanas antes por la cámara
baja del congreso esta ley va contra el
sentido común contra la ley natural
contra la misma razón sería un
avasallamiento de justamente de la misma
constitución nacional que defiende y
entiende que los derechos del niño y
cuando reconoce los derechos del niño
los reconoce desde el primer instante de
la concepción el proyecto ley
legalizaría el aborto hasta la semana 14
del embarazo y convertiría a argentina
en el país más grande de latinoamérica
en consagrar este derecho
la legislación cuenta con el apoyo del
presidente alberto fernández y con el de
cada vez más grupos feministas que están
planeando movilizarse este martes para
el debate pero
se espera que la votación en el senado
sea ajustada en un país en el que la
influencia de la iglesia católica es muy
fuerte la cámara alta rechazó una ley
similar en 2018 con el presidente macri
manteniéndose al margen del debate esta
vez los propulsores esperan que el nuevo
gobierno y su mayoría en el parlamento
sean suficiente para que argentina haga
historia
la organización reporteros sin fronteras
denunció que en 2020 han sido asesinados
50 periodistas
3 - que en 2019 en su último informe la
ong advirtió sobre la situación en
países que no están en guerra donde
ocurrió el 68% de los asesinatos entre
ellos están méxico con 8 pakistán e
india con 4 y filipinas y honduras con 3
y la violencia mundial sigue afectando a
los periodistas algunos pueden pensar
que los reporteros son solo víctimas de
los riesgos de su profesión pero son
cada vez más atacados cuando investigan
o cubren temas delicados lo que se está
atacando es el derecho a estar informado
que es un derecho de todos fin del
informativo volvemos en breve con más
noticias
[Música]